hello beautiful people i'm alana and
today we are watching the official
trailer for she-hulk attorney at lol
coming to disney plus i believe this
year
um
i
have actually been a she-hult friend for
a pretty long time i think i started
reading she-hulk comics just after
marvel vs capcom 3 came out which was
2011
because i liked playing her and i was
always kind of interested in i thought
she was very goofy to begin with and
then felt like she was very cool the way
she was represented in that game and got
kind of caught up in a lot of the hype
so what i want from this trailer
is just i'm just
just a huge muscly woman
but i do also think that they could lean
into the law aspects in really
interesting ways so it's going to be an
interesting balance i don't think it's
necessarily an easy thing for a team to
tackle so
let's see this just came out
uh seven hours ago at the time of
recording so let's take a look
being a superhero
is a trial by fire
who's gonna protect the world it's not
people like you
[Music]
i mean she ripped i'm jennifer walters
i'm a lawyer i have great friends can we
get some shots please it's an emergency
a demanding job we just started a
superhuman law division and i want you
to be the face of it
and a frustrating family because we
didn't ask for this
but you still got to deal with it
your transformations are triggered by
anger and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
nice
yes
i just want something normal anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where she-hulk is
jen you're a story now
girl your ass looks crazy whoa what the
[ __ ]
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
i
have stopped even like watching this
trailer
i hope this isn't just me because if it
is people getting very mad at me
the cg looks
really bad
like the way that she-hulk
looks
that looks okay
there was a shot here of her moving to
be a normal anonymous lawyer can you
tell us where she-hulk is jen eurus i
haven't seen
anything that disney has put out look
that like
stiff and video gamey lawyer can you
tell us where she-hulk is jen you're a
story now
what your ass looks crazy okay i'm just
gonna let that slide i'm sorry to keep
jumping around we're just gonna go back
to like here where i stopped paying
attention because i got distracted by
the cg
yes yes yes
no
no
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where she-hulk is
jen you're a story
now girl your ass looks crazy right now
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s yeah this is the best
date i've had in a while oh should we
split some fries
let's get those to go
okay
um
okay wow i found the cg so off-putting
and i'm pretty sure i've said that in
trailer reactions before and people have
gotten upset with me hence my concern
people get upset with me all the time
who cares um
look like a video game look like a
cutscene
very weird um
so i would have liked her to be bigger
more muscly is my biggest thing
both the lawyer side but especially the
she-hulk side i would have liked her to
be more hulky um but it doesn't matter
like my stance with this stuff is always
the appearance not being exactly what i
want doesn't mean something's bad it not
being accurate to the comics doesn't
mean something's bad these things don't
have to be the same in fact i think it's
kind of boring if they are exactly what
you expect so
it's fine it would have been cool i like
a muscly woman i would have liked to see
her be a little bit bigger so i'm a
little bit bummed but it's not the end
of the world um
wasn't a fan of the sense of humor shown
in the trailer
um not terrible but just like very sort
of generic humor
uh is how that comes across it's just
like
you know a joke about batman and
some tinder references it's all just
like very easy
writing i think um so not a huge fan i
didn't find it like horribly off-putting
or anything just not generally my style
of um humor
and i do think that the conflict uh
which is one that has been explored in
the comics of her you know trying to
just live her life of her already high
pressure job and also deal with the fact
that she's goddamn she-hulk can be
really really interesting that duality
is interesting at the best of times
hannah montana you know it's been around
for a while a staple of storytelling
um this trailer definitely comes across
as though the show is written for a more
female audience which i think is really
cool um this is
of all of the
uh
marvel
they call it mcu in their own disney
plus series i don't know um it really
comes across like it is focused on the
female audience you know it's like
exploring the life of a woman who's
struggling with a high-profile job and
also dealing with the dating life and i
think that that's cool that generally
means it's not for me i don't tend to
watch a lot of um
rom commie
type stuff um
however i like that that they're doing
that that they're fulfilling a need for
that audience with a character who i
have liked for a very long time who i
think is a very cool woman is is
relatable in a bunch of ways um
even if we're not all green and muscly
so
yeah the the big takeaway for me is the
cg dude like
i'm like flabbergasted um
show looks fine ultimately i think like
there's cool stuff about it stuff i
didn't like i just found that cg so
jarring so let's take a look at some
comments
see if it's just me can't wait to find
out
uh probably a lot of people are gonna
have positive things to say about hulk
being present i don't doubt that great
to see hulk jumping again
people disagreeing with the humor in
this huh this is what she hulk is like
in the comics and in her first early
runs she's witty sarcastic and overall
comedian so to see this sort of humor
come through in an empty show like this
is great in comic book accuracy
i would agree that she's witty sarcastic
and funny and a little bit snarky
uh i don't feel like
this trailer
really did that
maybe that's just me
cg looks fine to me don't know why
everyone's complaining okay i guess
people did have the same problems
excited seems mostly positive here
seems like there's going to be a lot of
comedy pepin in the show and i'm looking
forward to it that's i mean i'd be super
surprised if that doesn't happen it
seems largely positive
light-hearted fun i would agree with
that i would agree with that
right makes it hilarious and totally out
there interesting
going to be incredible all right
i'm actually very happy to see the
internet respond to this so positively
this is a this is a fair take and
probably the one that i should strive to
have
uh j shock blah said looking forward to
this cgi looks a little weird but
whatever i get it as long as it's fun
i'll suspend my disbelief
it it's not she's not real
you know like
it should be on me to be like
they're gonna do what they can do on a
cheaper tv show it's not a marvel film
they are different so that that is
probably the correct take and i should
strive to be more like that person and
be like
it's fine
finally we see some hulks long overdue
and definitely hyped agree that i'm a
fan of of i i just like she hulk
cgi looks weird
agreed but as a hulk fan i'm actually
pretty hyped for this hope this is not
the finished product i would think that
it is the finished product
okay this is largely really positive and
i think i agree people saying it it
seems like it's um
light-hearted
fun and i would totally agree with that
the tone i think is nice
and again i feel like this is like
um
different it's different
to a lot of the other
comic book content it's less yeah it is
less serious it is a little more like i
said rom comey which i i should have
shouldn't i guess i shouldn't have said
it's just for women more people than
women like that but
obviously they have target markets when
they make this kind of stuff just it is
definitely a different tone and i
appreciate that i think it looks okay
i respect the the positivity in the
comments there
um
yeah i wasn't a fan of the humor it
seems very easy
and i do actually think that she-hulk is
actually quite funny where i didn't feel
like this was that but maybe that's just
me maybe i'm being picky i don't know
it looks it looks fine looks fun i
totally agree with that it looks fun and
that's a great takeaway to have i think
that cgi
just really
confused my brain
i don't know